I think your book is,
it is so timely and you obviously were working on it before everything
that happened with George Floyd and nationwide, it's called five days.
And it's about, uh, the five days at the center of the, um,
Freddie gray protests. Obviously you're in Baltimore right now.
You're from Baltimore. Uh, and so the city is near and dear to your heart. Um,
how did you experience, um, those protests in real time? Um,
and then how did this book come about?
You know,
I remember the whole thing kind of a gun began when I was sitting in,
in Freddie Gray's funeral. And, and for those who, who might not remember,
you know, Freddie gray was a, a 25 year old young man, uh,
in Baltimore who made eye contact with police and ran. Um,
the reason I say that is because that was his crime was if you are in
a high crime, oftentimes high poverty area,
making eye contact with police and running is enough to trigger probable cause
had he done that in a wealthy neighborhood, he'd been going for a jog,
but he makes eye contact with police and runs in Harlem park
Sandtown-Winchester, which were two areas of Baltimore, West Baltimore,
deep poverty. And, uh,
he's arrested an hour after he's arrested he's in a coma.
And when he, the,
when he's finally taken to the university of Maryland medical center,
it is deemed that, uh,
he has three broken vertebrae and a crushed voicebox and a crushed larynx.
And so there were protests that took place in Baltimore for two weeks after
domaining justice and accountability saying, you know, how was someone arrested?
And an hour later they're in a coma and no one has an answer for what happened.
And, uh, and the morning of his funeral,
I went to the funeral and Andrew was crazy because I remember sitting in the
back of the church and I didn't feel like I had earned the right to make that
walk up, to go view the body.
So I just sat in the back and I left the funeral and
I had to fly to Boston to give a talk on poverty.
And the irony of that hit me really hard that
the night of his funeral was the night that Baltimore started this
process.
And that's when you saw the unrest take place literally to the point that by six
o'clock that night, the governor had called in the national guard, uh, and,
and put Baltimore under a state of emergency in a curfew. And, um,
and I found myself in Boston talking about poverty,
both because of the work that I was doing.
Cause at that point I was running an organization, um, that I,
that I founded that focused on helping students jet first,
generally first-generation students make it and stay in college.
But I also knew that they were there to kind of talk about my past and my
background and, and put me up as an example.
And it was in that moment that I started realizing how dangerous
that was, how it made me complicit as well. Wow.
That, that we can sit there and say,
and look at the people who make it and say it's because of them.
And that's such a great story.
And then look at ones who don't and say it's because of them.
And it's because they didn't work hard without understanding the systems that we
still have in place.
That's what your book, the other Wes Moore is all about is that it's exactly.
Right. It's about the same.
Neighborhood and one winds up here and then the other one's up, uh, you know,
in jail.
That's right. And how,
and how we are so quick as a society to either congratulate or to castigate
without being willing to understand or indict systems that we have
in all of this. And I think about this in context, and, you know,
earlier on this week, uh, you know, we had, uh, the, the, the,
the current governor of Maryland, you know, he announced that he's petty,
he's putting, he's putting out a book, right. And in the book,
he starts talking a lot about, uh, this moment.
And he was the brand new governor. He think he was governor for, for, uh, for,
for three months at the time when everything jumped off with Freddie gray.
But during this book he's spends time. And, and,
and the exact quote that he used when he was describing the,
when describing Freddie gray was he called him a Crips gang connected
street level drug dealer with a long criminal rap sheet.
I spent four years focusing on and understanding what happened around Freddie
gray and what happened in Baltimore around those times. And,
and here's what I do know.
And I can say this definitively that the story of Freddie Gray's life is a story
of societal failure,
because this was a young man who was born underweight and premature.
He was also born addicted to heroin because his mother battled heroin addiction
for much of her life. She grew up in deep poverty, her entire life.
She gives birth to twins. Once the twins are old enough to,
they actually gain enough weight, that they're able to leave the hospital.
They move into a housing project on North Carrie street over in,
over in West Baltimore.
And that housing project in 2009,
along with 480 other homes were actually cited in a civil lawsuit
because of the endemic levels of lead inside of that house. You know, and, and,
you know, it's just like, you know, the CDC, right?
The center for disease control indicates that if a person has six milliliters of
lead in every deciliter of blood, but never deciliter of blood,
that person will have cognitive damages for the remainder of their life. Right.
We've known this as a neurotoxin for a century. If a person has six,
Freddie gray had 36.
So this was a young man who was born premature underweight,
addicted to heroin and lead poisoned.
And by that time in his life, he's too.
And so when we're making these judgments about people,
by the time he was in fifth grade,
he was four grade levels behind in reading of the cognitive damage of,
of the lead poisoning. You know,
he finished his last recorded day of school in the Baltimore city school system
was in 10th grade. And he was 19 years old.
He had been in special education classes,
his entire academic career because of the lead poisoning. And so when we're, um,
I'm hearing this, uh, where, where, you know,
hearing the current governor making points about how well, you know,
he was a, he was, no, he was no choir boy. He was no singer in the church choir.
I know he wasn't, but I also know this is that Freddie gray never had a shot.
Freddie gray never had a chance.
And that was the point of all of this is that we have to understand all of these
moments and all of these periods.
We have got to understand it with a sense of context, because the truth is,
is that every system that touched Freddie's life,
whether it was the health system or the housing system or the education system,
or our policing system, that it not only failed to help him,
but it did severe and lasting damage.
And now we see the product.
Yeah. And he dies in police custody after an hour. I mean, like that,
that's like the brutal end, you know, to,
to a story of institutional, uh, failure. Uh,
and the, the tough part of it is that, like,
if you have a set of systems or an economy,
that's grinding people up and then someone
dies as a result. Uh, it's almost like a reflex to say, well,
what was wrong with this person? Uh, you know, because that,
that's actually a more comforting stance and narrative than to
say, like, wait a minute, like maybe we've had, uh,
problems up and down for years and decades and generations, uh,
or even the fact that in his case, I mean, you know,
he's born to a mother who's addicted to heroin. I mean,
you could probably trace some, some, uh, um, problems even before he was born,
um, to, to various failures. And th this is something so that the book,
one of the things in the book that struck me was, um, there's a woman, uh,
I believe her name is Tawanda Jones and she's,
she's protesting like, um,
I believe it was a brother or like someone else who, uh,
who was a victim of police violence. And, uh,
so she's holding like weekly protests before Freddy, uh,
dies. And,
and then the Freddie gray protest ended up getting built into like a
preexisting. And this struck me forcibly, cause you're like, wow,
this is like a constant sort of waterfall of impacted
families and protests that preexist any one person where everyone's looking
around being like, who are you protesting? Because they had like,
like different family members who'd been, uh, victimized.
So that was one thing where I was like, wow,
like if you're in that environment like that, that, that is, uh,
mind blowing for most, um, tele Andrew, one.
Of the most fascinating things for me about the project of writing five days was
first identifying who were the people that I wanted to follow over this five day
period. And that I wanted to,
I wanted the reader to be able to walk through this era,
walk through this chaos, through their eyes, through the eyes of these people.
And one of the first people I knew that I was like,
I got to make sure she's profiled is to want to Jones.
And because it's important to remember that even in the two years before
Freddie gray, right, right. There was Chris Brown,
there was Anthony Anderson and there was her brother,
Tyrone West, and every Wednesday still to this day, in fact,
she just had the 371st straight West Wednesday where
every Wednesday she protests.
Sometimes it's just her and maybe one other person.
And sometimes she's got hundreds of people with her, but rain, sleet,
snow doesn't matter. She protests.
And she protests the fact that even prior to all this where she was
in and she found herself and that's having these amazing conversations with her
where she would say, you know,
I was so proud to March with the gray family when they called me and asked me,
and I was so proud of the fact that the city was standing up and saying,
you know, yes, we want justice and yes, we have to address policing.
But she said,
but I just also felt a certain type of way where I still thought to myself,
but where was this when my brother was killed, right. Where was this?
When my brother's body was literally left in the middle of the street with mace
all over him and boot prints all over his body, where was this?
And so she, every Wednesday,
she protests demanding justice and accountability for what happened to her
brother. And she was,
she was such a fascinating person to follow over that five day period,
especially when you look at it in context of who some of the other people were,
right. So you had to Wanda, but then I also, you know,
going to spend time following a major Marc party,
who was a Baltimore city police major who grew up in West Baltimore.
And I remember him specifically telling me before we, he said, listen, you know,
I know that none of my colleagues woke up that morning with homicide in their
mind. But I also know that for kids in West Baltimore, I grew up,
I know why they don't believe me, right. Or,
or following someone like Greg Butler, who's a basketball star,
turned protester, or following someone like John Angelos.
Who's the son of the owner of the Baltimore Orioles, literally, you know,
a billionaire who was also the head of baseball operations for the Orioles
and base. And,
and on the Wednesday after baseball played its first ever game with no fans.
Now we're doing all the time, but their first ever game with no fans,
when the Orioles play the Chicago white Sox.
And it was because John Angeles was one of the people in the room making the
final decision of basically saying, no, we should play the game.
Even though the city is in a state of emergency because the world needs to see
this.
And so watching various and different perspectives of people like that,
people like, and Nick Mosby,
who's a city Councilman at the time whose wife was the state's attorney in
Baltimore, but watching it through their eyes, I think, uh, you know,
hopefully provided a real kaleidoscope understanding of the complexity of the
moment. But also that if we thought that this was just about
policing or just about Freddy,
that we're missing a bigger point,
that society was trying to tell us something else that they were hoping that we
would actually pay attention to.
Well, there, there was another fact in the, uh,
Towanda Jones narrative that also hit me really hard, which was that, um,
and I'm not sure if it was for her brother or for another, uh, victim,
but that they essentially settled for a million dollars and gave
it to the three survivors of the victim of police brutality.
Um, and that struck me because it was a situation where it's like, well,
you clearly know that something went terribly wrong if you were settling with a
family, but, but there's no, um,
like no arrests made no accountability. It's just like, there's a death.
And then there's like some, uh, some money. And one of the things that, uh,
I found when I was researching the extent of the problem of police misconduct
was that that actually happens all over the country where they're,
they're settling these civil judgments to the tune of over a billion dollars a
year in the aggregate. Um, and,
and so that's their way of papering over this problem. Um,
and so if you think about like the,
the number of times that happens and no one gets a dime or the
number of times it happens in someone sues and it's completely unsuccessful
because the, can you imagine trying to Sue your local police department? I mean,
that, that sounds, uh, like very, very difficult to me, you know, like, uh,
like you, you feel like everything would be uphill.
So the fact that you're still getting a billion dollars under those conditions
struck me as a sign, that the problem is orders of magnitude bigger.
Like if you had to try and throw a measurement on it, you were like,
police are causing billions of dollars of, uh,
bodily harm to Americans every single year. Uh,
and the fact that that was happening in Baltimore where there's like,
no real responsibility, but here's some but like blood money essentially.
It's like, Hey, we killed your dad, but you know, here's a little bit of money.
Like maybe that makes up for it. Like that also hit me really hard.
It w and honestly,
and I think Towanda story is such a powerful one around it because she didn't
take any money. And it was for that reason,
because they also knew that with taking the payment meant, there was also a,
you know, there was also essential.
Agreement to never talk about this.
And she's like, I'm not going to stop talking about it.
So she never took any money for, and, and I, and,
and you bring up an incredibly important point because there is this narrative
about Baltimore when people say, so what, what brought the temperature down?
What calmed everything down in Baltimore. And, and oftentimes the narrative is,
well, it was when the national guard were called in, right.
That's not true because, you know, first of all, I can,
I can tell you as a person who, you know, very proudly wore the uniform,
you know,
oftentimes when you introduce military personnel in the situations that doesn't
calm situations now, right. But the second thing,
and the most important thing to remember is those are some of the biggest
protests that were going to take place in Baltimore were actually set to take
place the Saturday after the unrest, what happened,
why those protests never happened?
It wasn't because the national guard was there.
The national guard was already there when they were being planned.
What happened was, was when the state's attorney,
Marilyn Mosby announced she was pressing charges against the six officers.
Because up until that point, you're absolutely right.
Andrew it's like th th the thread was common, right? Something happened,
a payout ensued, and it went away.
That was a general trend, right?
But this was the first time in Baltimore history
where the state's attorney was actually saying, no,
I'm actually pressing charges against these officers for misconduct.
I remember being there.
And you're where there was almost this celebratory vibe throughout the streets
of Baltimore. Cause people were shot. People are like, what, wait, what, wait.
She announced what?
That they're arresting the officers for that because we hadn't,
we had never seen before. And now granted fast forward, you know, we had,
two of the officers were found not guilty for the officers where their case that
their charges were were, were, were dismissed. Um, but that moment,
that was what actually what brought the temperature down because people thought
for the first time, we actually might see justice. And what's interesting. Now,
I think even when you look at what happened with what's happened with George
Floyd,
one of the big differences I think between then and now is the bar has been
risen where at that point, the charges were like,
Whoa, that's a big deal, calmed everything down. Now,
charges have been filed the bar isn't about charges anymore,
the bars convictions. And that's going to be the real test to see,
can you actually get convictions for, you know, for, for these,
for these instances, in the case of torch Floyd,
when you were literally watching a grown man in handcuffs on the
ground with another man nonchalantly leaning his knee into his neck until he can
no longer breathe. I mean, the bar is not, can we get an arrest, the bar,
his conviction for that?
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.